e
e e
good morning I'm going to open up the
subcommittee uh for the family court uh
the special committee for the title for
subcommittee so last week we had met or
not last week two weeks ago we had or
September 17th we had met and we
discussed what we had been tasked with
which was researching title four funding
how much is collected how how why and
where it goes which representative Smith
was able
to give us a nice document that had come
from the LBA audit which showed where
all of those went it was clearly
documented for parts a b d and e 66% of
the funding comes federally and the
remainder is through the state budget
and the majority of all of the
administration was through DHHS and the
four areas where the court administered
was establishing the uniform support
order establishing paternity when
necessary if a party is refusing testing
modification of uniform support orders
every three years if a party requests or
sooner if there was a significant change
and then show cause hearings and that
was the the four Family Court areas and
then in Superior Court a criminal
nonsupport cases are through the
superior court and those cases are
really rare less than 10 a year we left
there
and uh attorney bristen had offered to
send us a lot of documentation which she
did I passported along to everybody and
that was where we had last left off so
just to do a quick recap because it had
been a few weeks wanted to make sure
we're all on the same page so now I
wanted to see where everybody was at
based on the documentation what we
talked
about last week I'm hoping to wrap this
up today so that we're ready for the
final meeting on
10:22 which which will vote on the
report of the entire subcommittee so
we'll need to send our report in order
to be able to do that so um who would
like to start
representative
ball I'm sorry I was just looking at
some of the paperwork before could would
we mind if we started on the other side
of the room
please representative Smith or
representative long do you have anything
that you wanted
to representative
W yeah I I I think we uh I think it's
articulated well where how much comes in
from where and where it goes um and I
think that report itself uh would be
what the committee would
need
um yeah
that's okay thank you basically it okay
thank you representative long
representative Smith did you have
anything you wanted to add um I I agree
with representative long um I I'm not
sure that this topic
really
belongs um under the um jurisdiction of
this special committee as it
was described to us when the committee
was formed but since it was sent here we
did what we could I think we
evaluated the information that came in
it seems to make sense it confirms what
all of us know and that is that what
happens in the family court is very
complicated very
challenging and that um
uh as to those areas that go directly to
the court um and
obviously the um Department also
Department of Health and Human Services
has significant responsibilities in this
area and
um in terms of the legislative action I
don't see
any I don't at the moment see any
legislation which is necessary to be
proposed other than the
general areas that we have spoken about
overarching the fact that um there is
not enough support for the family court
judges to be able to carry out their
responsibilities and we should be
encouraging
more um uh clerk support and other kinds
of support for the judges so that they
can handle these CL cases
um as well as it's possible to handle
such challenging work
thank you representative Smith
yes what was the
perception um during testimony that
there's a reason
why um there's a there's a reason why
some of this comes forward is because
the state looks to go after the Federal
funds is that was that a perception that
we heard through
testimony is that the reason is that one
of the reasons why we're looking at this
so I don't want to assign motive to
somebody else but I do believe that what
we heard in testimony was that others
perceived that there was an
incentive
for judges to make certain findings in
order to be able to get federal funds
is I believe part of what we heard and I
think we've now demonstrated that the
amount of money in fact that the family
court gets from the federal funding from
title for is in fact less than 1% of
their overall budget so I
think the data speaks for itself on that
right okay
representative
ball I believe in the testimony we heard
um or I heard uh some concerning uh
things that I think need to be addressed
but I don't think they fall within
necessarily the purview of this
committee um so I think that something
that um I may look into but I think that
we need to stay within the perview of
our assignment do you want toow
elaborate it all so I did I did discuss
briefly with chairman Pearson just to
make sure that I was understanding the
assignment correctly and he did say that
if something was uncovered as part of
the subcommittee it could be something
that could be discussed but we
weren't I guess to be digging in on
those areas so are you may ask if you
referring to the garnishment of
wages uh yes I am um that I found very
concerning just in hearing it and then
um what I found out after the meeting
con made me concerned about it even
more um because there still is in this
day a stigma attached to wage
garnishment that the parent is for no
other lack of a better word a dead be um
which is not the case and that's what my
concern was when I was hearing the
testimony that people just check a box
and one party one who's receiving the
money could check the box and the other
party who's responsible for paying has
no say they're automatically put into
wage
garnishment
um what I was surprised at what I
learned afterwards is that a person that
has wage garnishment it could impact
their ability to get a job that requires
security clearance and I was not aware
of that uh when when I was listening to
the test I just didn't like the whole
way that that was done without having
someone say but it's my understanding at
least years ago um and um it is today as
well that if a person has a job or is
looking for a job that requires a top
secret clearance that this would
disqualify them because of the stigma
attached to um a wage garnishment the
assumption is they're not making
payments or they're having money
problems and therefore can't be in a job
that would require that type of
security I was a little bit I was like
okay well that's top secret clearance
but then when I spoke to a local police
officer police
chief when I mentioned to him what do
you think about wage garnishment and his
immediate response was that's precursor
in other words that person would be put
to the end of the line I mean that
person could get a job but they would
have to jump through so many Hoops to
prove that this person is not a threat
um is not having financial problems or
anything that could get in their way of
performing their
Duty um and that to me is extremely
concerning and that's where I go back
and I say that the wage
garnishment in my
opinion needs to be shown that it's
necessary rather than just somebody
wants it um and I I would like to look
into that a little bit in deeper
detail thank you representative all
representative Smith thank you I I want
to ask you a question before I I proceed
should we do we want to discuss this
here or do we just want to acknowledge
representative B's concern that she
might now pursue through other
areas so I did bring this specific issue
up with chairman Pearson since it had
been discussed last time and he was okay
with the committee
potentially making including it as part
of their
report but just not I guess kind of
further going down the path of looking
into DHHS because we're really supposed
to focus on the family
court I I agree with that conclusion
that this is not a topic for this
committee and that's why I'm hesitant
because I don't want
to blor an issue that I don't think
belongs before us but I do respect my
colleague representative all and her um
her concerns about this I come down
however in a very different
place um if in fact an
individual has
agreed to pay child support which is
what we're talking about and then does
not and cannot present a
reason that's acceptable as to why not
then I believe that that person is in
violation of
um of of a decision about child support
and it does mean that that person's um
financial responsibilities are are such
that it might interfere with I'll say
his but it could be his or her um
ability to function in a job that
requires a high level of security or a
job such as in the police force and I
don't think that that's inappropriate I
do know that very few cases end
up going to the Superior Court in this
area I do know that the
threat of um uh imprisonment let's you
know be you is real enough to provide an
additional incentive to those people who
might rather spend their money in a
different way than meeting their agreed
upon obligations to their children
um and so the threat itself does have
some value
um but I think
people have to be held
accountable um and I understand that
there are people
who um whose financial situation changes
who responsibilities change and we ought
to be able to find a way to address that
but but someone walking away from their
responsibilities to support their
children are
not honoring their obligations to their
family and the community so I'm I'm not
uh I think I think the problem though
was that what was said was that even if
somebody was paying on time one party
could still fill out the application and
request for the wage G perishment even
if the party had always paid on time and
that that would be approved because that
doesn't go through Court that's just
through DHHS and so the concern was that
somebody who's always paid on time would
now have the wage garnishment even
though they'd always paid on
time I that might very well be true and
if so that's a problem and it's a
problem that falls to the Department of
Health and Human Services not to the
family
court and perhaps that can be handled in
rules perhaps that can be handled in
informal discussions with people in
responsible positions at Health and
Human Services and if necessary perhaps
it could be handled in
legislation but not through the special
committee on the Family
Court thank you
um I guess just to further understand
the depth of
it um attorney Briston would you mind if
I ask you a question and it's okay you
don't have to answer it and if you don't
know that's okay I I'm kind of calling
you out on the spotlight here but I I'm
wondering if you might be able to tell
us approximately how many like what
percentage of the cases that have wage
garnishment are not for non-payment so
and they're not tan up situations I know
you said approx a little less than 10%
were tanif but do you know approximately
what percentage are people that have
always paid on time but somebody just
would prefer to be paid through the
bureau um I'm not sure I
can parse those those numbers
um the court when it issues a child
support order um has a choice of which
box to check off on the uniform support
order which is one of the many documents
I sent to you guys um and it in it it it
has choices between payable to the
oblige bcss and
other we always um encourage the courts
to have it payable through us even if
neither of the parties
is wanting to go through us and then
they can handle their child support
between themselves
but having it payable through Us in that
order means that if when there's a
problem and many times there
is the um saying let's say mom is the
oblige if she needs to then get our
services if it's payable directly to her
she needs to go back to court and get it
payable through us so there so it is
required to be in the court order it's
not just that they can fill out an
application it it so it it does relate
to family court in the sense that if
it's not in the uniform support order
with the Box checked that it's payable
through
bcss then the person can't just fill out
an application to ask for your services
for wage garnishment it has to be
ordered through the court right then
we'd have to if it wasn't we'd have to
go back to the court to get it ordered
that's what the notice to make payable
process is and
uh definitely some hoops that have to go
that have to be jumped through to be
able to get to to get to that point and
generally if somebody's not paying
that's more time where payments are not
being
made um can I ask one further question
you said that if you encourage the box
to be checked to be paid through bcss
and not through the party so that if
they need help they could go through you
but does that mean even if that box is
checked the party could still the
parties could between themselves still
agree that party a pays party B and
doesn't go through you and that that
wouldn't be in violation of the court
order no
because it our our process is entirely
voluntary so if they haven't filed an
application we don't even necessarily we
don't even know about the case on the
order that it's payable through you they
don't actually have to do it
correct it is confusing we do get people
who come in and like it's payable
through you where's my money and we're
like well you have to apply for the
services
to to get that and that's a just a
learning thing that we have to teach the
courts and teach the clerks so that they
can tell people when that's up happening
thank you for answering that so I guess
it relates to the family court in the
sense that they can they're the ones who
approve the uniform support order or
order the uniform support order and
rather it's payable through the party or
bcss so that would be the relationship
with the court
there um did you have something you
wanted to add rep
well before we were um given the answers
I was going to say that my memory
recalled that this was through the court
order because it's part of the uh
parenting plan or the the child support
um and it was just checking the box so I
my memory my memory served me well for
once and um I do still have concerns
that and I and I totally respect that we
do have people that do not pay and we
need to have a formula or a way of
making sure they pay
um but it concerns
me that the assumption is the person
isn't going to pay before they prove
that they're not going to pay and um
given that there are negative
ramifications at least those
ramifications should be told before they
agree to um having the the wage
garnished um for those people who may
already be in a situation where the
they're a police officer or they're in a
a position that's bonded or some other
position that a grain to wage
garnishment could come back and bite
them um because they didn't realize
there is actually um a negative
consequence or possible
one yes representative Smith those are
very good points for representative B um
could I ask a question again
um
if you know the box is checked but the
parties have agreed to handle this
without involving
you um and if one of the parties then
applies for a
job is the fact that that box had been
checked something that is um
communicated to a potential
employer even
though they are handling the matter
themselves no I mean if we're not
involved in it we would have no contact
with the with the employer um unless
we're doing a weight assignment at which
point somebody would have had to apply
for apply for services thank you I did
go back to look through my personal
security clearance application and in
that application what it the the way
that it phrased the question was if you
had ever had your wages garnished for
any reason so if they're not actually
being garnished you wouldn't have to
check that
box I would think I mean that's how I
would interpret it that because it's I
mean I think it's pretty explicit if you
have had
them yes refall what I was told by the
police chief is that if someone put in
an application and they indicated that
they have wage garnishment that the um
Police Department would in its um
vetting of the
candidate um call the spouse um call
around find out why it's there and then
this was also come out when they have
polygraphs um in order to get their jobs
but but those are the Hoops that it's
like would does the police department
really want to jump through those Hoops
when there could be 15 other applicants
behind that don't have wage garnishment
and that they could push through um
expedite more quickly so my concern is
just as I said that it presents a
situation that I would like to just make
sure that people are aware of um and I
did have another clarifying
question
um if they if they don't sign that box
and they agree to the other but then
someone comes in and applies for an
application what happens in that
situation okay so if we have a the
uniform support order is payable between
the
parties and then Mom comes in and wants
our services whether she's sick of
dealing with Dad not paying her or
giving the check to the three-year-old
and thinking it's cute or there's a
Millions million different ways she she
files an application and then the case
needs to go back to court either through
a notice to make payable or a change to
the Uso to get to get it payable through
us and at that point there's also the
question of what the arear are if we
start off straight off being payable
through us then there's then there's no
aers um if say it takes six months for
Mom to file an
application she then fills out a
uh statement of rear of this is the
money I got this is the money I should
have gotten and then we have to give
that to Dad and there can be a
conversation as to what was paid and why
and that can get a little interesting
depending on depending on the parties
that's what I always say with regards to
to wage assignment I totally get what
you're saying about that is that for
some people the the talking about money
is the hardest thing for them and if if
you can take the money off the table
where money gets paid before anybody
sees it so you don't feel it's lost
quite so much that it it really um
Smooths things out between the parties
and then of course we have the we have
the record
keeping for a
clarification um is it possible in these
situations for the uh parties to be
encouraged to engage in
the online payment services right
directly through their Banks to make
sure that these things happen and checks
go directly rather than going through
you it's just tell them look if you want
to go and you're going to pay amongst
yourself we highly recommend that you
set it up as an automatic payment to
make sure that we don't have you know so
there it seems to me that there is a
remedy in this day and age to get people
to pay automatically through their bank
and that's not saying that there's not
people out there who are not going to do
that we always going to have that
segment of the population again my
concern is casting such a a broad net
that we're catching people that would
not be in that situation um but are then
finding themselves in a in a quantry
later oh uh using any kind of means like
that is definitely something that's
anticipated by the court um that's that
other sort of box of setting up um
automatic withdrawals checking count to
checking count that's literally as much
as I know about that type of stuff but
it it's definitely something that's
that's contemplated and there are boxes
that you check off
about in the the law requires that that
wage assignment be considered in the
first instance but if the parties agree
excuse me um you check off a box and and
you sort of you go from
there I'm sorry would you mind
clarifying what you mean the law
requires that wage assignments wage
assignment be considered in the first
instance could you explain that a little
further I have the stat P up but I'm
just so 458b
collection and dispers and sorry 458 BC
this is Roman numeral 3 Collection and
dispersement of all support orders
initially issued by the state after
1994 shall be enforced through the state
dispersement
unit where the obligor is subject to an
income withholding pursuance went to
458b yeah is is bcss the state
dispersement unit the state dispersement
unit is a is a contractor of B of
bcss that's where all the all the funds
get are payable to the the state
dispersed unit they've got a so off
which are not being enforced by the
department does that mean not being
enforced by DHHS yes shall be enforced
through the state dispersement unit
where the obligor is
subject to income
withholding whether or not the obligate
has applied for 40
services this actually I'm sorry this is
referring to we have
a a different category of withholding
that that we call non4
D where if somebody wants just the wages
piece but doesn't want the rest of the
enforcement um because they want the
recordkeeping we have we have the
ability to to do that so basically we
put the wage assignment in place we keep
the records but if somebody stops paying
somebody loses their job that isn't
making the payments we don't
then do any enforcement that's left on
their side of course they can always
come back and apply for 40 Services if
they want but we have about last time I
checked it we had about 30 of those
cases where they're just using it
for um The Collection piece so this is
talking about dispersing monies uh the
collection and the dispersement of money
so is this law implying that if the
order is after 1994 that it's supposed
to go through bcss yeah I'm sorry if you
if you if we back up one and go to 458
B2
and it's a confusing stat statute
because of because of all the dates but
basically uh Roman numeral one
says child support spousal support or
combination issued after 1994 whether
payable through the department or
directly to an oblige shall include a
provision assigning a portion of the
oor's income salaries commission
earnings or other periodic income from
whatever
Source uh except as expressly limited by
law or otherwise provided in the
section if the state is paying public
assistance for the benefit of the minor
children the assignment shall be
required and shall take effect
immediately in all other case where the
state is not paying Public Assistance
the assignment shall be suspended by the
court where there's an agreement by a
written agreement between the oor and
the oige and the court approves
it there they do put language in here
and I haven't seen this in a while but
just because I think technology has
moved on um in a it talks about provided
the court may require the establishment
of a dedicated checking account so
that's that type of I'll put money in
your account so part A means that the
default
is that it goes between bcss unless the
parties agree otherwise is that and
that's because the statute says that 458
B2 correct comma
I a right
right okay and then C goes on to talk
about for good cause to not require
immediate income assignment and then
there needs to be a a finding as to why
implementing immediate assignment would
not be in the best
interests and usually proof that the
fact that the obligor has been paying
timely in the past is usually what the
Court's looking for if you're if you're
at a hearing and maybe this is the first
time they've dealt with the issue of
Child Support
um if Mom comes in and says yeah he's
been paying me the you know the six
weeks it took for us to get here and I
have no problem with you know he's going
to pay me great we check off the Box
he's made timely payments and and we we
go on we go on our way and is there a
federal law that's requiring this to be
done or is this just the way that New
Hampshire does it um to your
knowledge I'm pretty sure it's required
by the feds to have the wage assignment
be through through
yes okay
um
so I
guess I mean I I guess that's something
we would have to if it's federally
required then we can't change it but I
guess that's something I I'd like to
look into to see where it's federally
required because if it's not federally
required and we're requiring it in this
statute then we're not giving the court
the ability unless the parties agree
we're not giving the report the ability
to
say it doesn't have to go through
bcss and I would say
that would be a flaw if it's not
federally
required that we're kind of tying the
Court's hands to say it has to go
through bcss for wage garnishment and
then the person's going to have to
answer that on
their
potential job application background
check type of documentation I don't
um yes representable um I do think we
need to look at that closer because I
recall the testimony or the the
discussion not testimony sorry um last
time was saying that the federal
government only required those receiving
tanif had to be on the system and that
the other people it was just a matter of
checking a box on the court order and it
um if it's if it's federally required
then I'm not really understanding why
they're even checking the Box so I'm
guess I'm a little bit conf I gu guess
because the parties agree if they agree
and then I was looking at the form if
they agree and sign the form that they
agreed otherwise the judge at the
bottom just orders it but didn't you
just say that basically everyone it was
federally required well unless the
parties agree was what the what the
exemption said here was that
um um that's what I thought I that's
what I thought I heard then I thought I
heard it not that way and now I'm
hearing it back that way so I'm a little
bit confused as to which way it's saying
where there's a written agreement
between the obligor and oblige that's
approved by the
court
um I mean I guess that that's something
that we could
good I guess that's something that we
could ask just to be checked before like
the next meeting if that is federally
required because that might be something
that we want to consider just discussing
I mean what what do you guys think is
that if if that's not federally required
do you think it's something worth
mentioning in our report that may be
considered for future
legislation I think that complicates um
that well it's easily
misunderstood uh if it's not required
federally and we adding it in uh it
creates some
complications do you agree
representative Smith or have F okay
so outside of this one unanswered
question that we
have does anybody have anything else
that they feel relative to title 4 in
the Family Court
committee that needs to be mentioned in
our
report and I do intend to include as
part of our
report the documentation that
representative Smith found from the LBA
because that shows us exactly how where
why
um and what I had mentioned at the
beginning when I
summarized about the exact pieces those
five pieces four in Family Court one in
Superior Court that the court deals with
relative to title 4 just so that we're
abundantly clear exactly I think we've
figured out exactly you know what the
court is doing the Court's relationship
with title 4 verse what might just be
DHHS is piece so with all of that in
there I
can write something up
um do we need to vote on specific
language here or we've agreed to what
we're going to put in and it can just be
submitted and then the we'll vote on the
full report as a whole is that I could
send it as a draft and then individually
if anybody has input they want to give
if I miss something that way we don't
have a quorum outside of the meeting I
would suggest that that's the way to do
it you know you put the draft together
and send it to us and if we catch
something
that needs to be looked at we just
contact you perfect did you have
anything else rep ball or
no I totally agree thank you thank you
okay so I think that concludes what we
were looking into unless anybody else
has anything else they wanted to add and
I also want to offer if attorney bristen
had anything else you wanted to add
um thank you so much did you find it
very still
looking
okay thank you I I would like to thank
the department for um really
going the
mile uh to help us with a very
complicated area yeah I'd also like to
to Echo that sentiment I really
appreciate you getting all of that
documentation together for us it was
certainly very
helpful answered a lot of questions and
I appreciate you being here as a
resource for us to ask all those
questions you're very knowledgeable in
the area and we definitely would have
had a much harder time trying to
navigate this without you so I truly
appreciate and and thank you for the
time thank you so much and thank you to
the committee for being here for all the
meetings we didn't have to cancel any of
them so we got our work done I
appreciate everybody so thank you all
I'm going to close the hearing unless
somebody had anything they wanted to add
thank you so
much for